u.s housing gained almost 7 trillion
dollars in value in 2021 shattering the
previous record for a single year the
u.s housing market is now worth twice as
much as it was 10 years ago in the
middle of the great recession that's
according to a recent zillow study
bianca holman shares advice from one
local realtor on navigating the market
here in southern nevada
i say if you're thinking about buying
it's never the wrong time to start now
sarah pulin is a real estate agent in
the valley a major focus for her besides
selling homes is teaching people about
the importance of home equity we have no
supply
and supply a lot of people were
expecting after you know everybody was
laid off during coronavirus that we were
going to get an influx of foreclosures
while a lot of people had equity in
their homes so when you have skin in the
game you're not going to release that
asset as easily as you were with this
past bubble that happened back in 2007
2008. we checked out the latest numbers
from the las vegas realtors for the
month of february the median price for
an active single family home listing was
485 thousand dollars and the median
price for a single family home sold was
450 thousand dollars i think with
interest rates going up this year it's
going to slow the demand but it's just
going to look like a little bit more of
a healthy appreciation from articles to
social media hulen says read as much
information as you can and work with a
real estate agent that can help you find
the right home ownership program for you
and the right property to fit your
budget it's very important in being
confident about making such a large
purchase this is going to be one of the
biggest investments that you make in
your life so you're going to want to do
your research